i met a guy and i haven't heard from him
and it's i don't know how that be
that is no porcupine we got fcu
porcupine in the building
i'm so happy
i don't want to be a hulk
but there are upsides your ass looks
crazy right now
this is the best date i've had in a
while
i will never get over
her picking up that man to go do the
sexy time because i wish that were me
let's be real i wish that were me
oh my god just kidding
am i really not really uh but anyways
welcome back to the rockstars with
she-hulk only a little bit more than a
week away we are so close to seeing the
hulk family finally get the attention
that they deserve in a dedicated hulk
series that apparently will find
jennifer walters in a support group led
by emil beat a brother and harlem
blonsky with a comic accurate mcu
porcupine what what the [ __ ]
we're trying new things out who knows
what's going to be the final one
a little corny honestly that's how
writers work we see what sticks and
maybe this one who knows
i'm down for any suggestions throw us
your suggestions in the comments and
that's it there you go but this is
inside marvel new rock stars weekly
marvel reaction show and after show my
name is mt and eric is out this week
because he did a little thing called
holy matrimony and falling in love which
is you know pretty great and he's
getting married to the love of his life
this week so congratulations to the boss
family eric voss we love you
i hope you had a great wedding and you
know have are filled with love you you
and your lovely fiancee slash now wife
are filled with all the love in the
world
the end
i'm ridiculous um but lucky for all of
us with me today is the wonderful and
super knowledgeable jessica clemens uh
hello jess how are you doing today i'm
good we just got finished shooting the
break room which is our weekly news show
our daily nerd news show and i was
staying on my shirt because i was
blindfolded and had to eat spaghetti and
bananas so
if you're wondering more stain yeah if
you're wondering what that show's about
maybe just go check it out yeah check
out the break room because the break
room is so much fun and like all the
funniest people at the office are on the
break room so check that out immediately
uh but also jessica clemens will also
coincidentally be covering all of our
she-hulk breakdowns in the future which
i am super excited about because jess
knows how to break something down like
bro if you've ever seen her the boys
break down stop what you're doing go
watch that because
she's she's killing it she's killing it
no i just can't break bones
i can break bones and break kneecaps
they said who looks most like she-hulk
in the office and then they asked me to
do it
and then they're like jessica's tall and
strong
is jessica green who knows um
i get green um when i um eat too much
chipotle and i get really nauseous um
and the avocado turns me green i don't
know what i'm saying but anyway
got it got it got it it's all the
avocado really but we of course i forgot
to talk about our girl jennifer walters
today on inside marvel because she hulk
is very close and things are getting
really weird in the she-hulk trailer
like she's in a support group why like
did she do something wrong like why did
you in trouble like did she hulk out too
much what did you do jen what did you do
but before we do that please be sure to
go to rockstarsmerch.com today to pick
up our newest latest obsession shirt
inspired by thor love and thunder and
all of our amazing merch options over at
new rockstars merch because when you do
it supports the channel so much and like
it is the best way to look good while
doing that so head on over to
newrockstarsmerch.com
today immediately with post haste do not
wait grab your mother's debit card don't
do that don't steal it for your mom all
right uh all right jess what is our
first question for today
our first question after stealing from
your mother's wallet is what is
abomination up to is he genuine who is
in his support group yes because in this
new trailer we see a lot of weird
characters in the support group and
right off the bat i've got to say
whoever's idea it was to put porcupine
in the mcu in his comic accurate glory
bless you and your entire family for
several generations because my god do i
love seeing a good comic accurate
ridiculous hero or villain and uh yeah
that uh that they straight up 3d print
they straight up 3d porque printed that
prickly patootie right from the pages
sweet jesus my god but porcupine of
course his name is alexander gentry in
the comics and he first made his
appearance in 1963's tales to astonish
number 48 as a villain to both ant-man
and the wasp and
he was originally a weapons designer who
thought building this monstrosity of a
porcupine suit was a great idea and it
was the future of warfare
it wasn't and so he had to turn to a
life of crime instead
to pay his bills because by god why
would you do that like could you could
you can you picture any soldier in a
porcupine like i don't think it is
it's uh outwardly ridiculous but the
idea that the porcupine spikes could
shoot out as darts and kill people along
with his like poisonous gas that he
released that's what makes it a very
evil and an evil invention so
like a bow and arrow like someone that
uses like any kind of weaponry that you
have to go back and get
maybe in the long term it doesn't sound
effective
but he has to pick up his quills every
time
i don't remember if he can just like
re-get more but it sounds like you run
out eventually like like hawkeye it's
like eventually you run out though
and then you gotta go back and forth
quills like i wonder i wonder if you
like shoot somebody in the neck he's
like hey can i get that back like i
don't have a lot of these thank you
just pulled it out it's like all right
i'm gonna put it back on my body all
black i think they they didn't want to
buy his weapon because it was so
ridiculous and he was like
well it's a great invention and you
don't have enough money to service me
for this weapon so i'm just gonna leave
and i'm just like
your weapon was stupid in the first
place
it is very stupid as a war weapon but
like you said it is a terrifying uh
weapon if you're a villain if i heard
that there was a real live porcupine
just shooting people with quills
that's i would it would be horrifying
the cartoons like most
most older comics make him look
ridiculous it looks like a bunch of like
wheat it looks like he's a scarecrow
so like
he looks much more terrifying in that
clip for the right uh for she-hulk than
that image right there
right because we do get a close-up of
his quills and like very briefly and
it's like holy [ __ ] those are sharp
those are very sharp quills so like who
knows who that uh how many people he's
turned into spongebob squarepants with
those quills my god we also have the
villain man bull in this trailer who
made his first appearance in 1971's
daredevil number 78 whose real name is
also william torrance which is the but
he goes by bull torrens because you know
taurus torrens because he's a bull
very very very clever marvel and he
actually got turned into a man bull by
an android after failing to kidnap test
subjects for mutation experiments and uh
he was originally a daredevil villain so
maybe there's a chance that we could
this is the person that daredevil is
chasing in the trailers um this this
ridiculous man bowl man because
he's a daredevil villain um but yeah
what do you think about this dude like
do you think he could actually be a
major player or is he just like a joke
here i don't think any of these people
are major players
i you don't think porcupines behind the
whole fc baseball i 100 but then again i
was also like mt stop bringing up frog
man he's never gonna show up
look who look who showed up who look who
was wrong
literally like i love this show
specifically because they are pulling up
the most ridiculous characters in marvel
history like all of them like man bull
porcupine like frogman sorry i love i
just love the ridiculous aspects of
comic books being brought to live action
it's why i love peacemaker like
peacemakers just all right
but like what i find interesting about
mandible is that we know the ceo of
roxanne is the minotaur who is a bull
man so i'm wondering if the minotaur has
anything to do with his transformation
in the mcu which would be really
interesting because we know that rock's
on exactly
they could easily make that connection
it wouldn't hurt anybody to make that
connection right because like
roxanne is all about energy and like
using radiation and stuff so i feel like
that makes sense um to mutate this weird
man but we also have another criminal in
this group that a lot of people don't
know about by the name of el aguila um
which is you know
i've never met one el aguila fan so if
you're gonna come out here and say like
yo i can't wait for him
some of y'all lie all the
time y'all just want to be on
the ride for every person that you don't
know and it's okay honestly i give you
more respect to be like i don't know who
this person is
just like i will say right now i don't
know who this person is i had no idea
who this man was until the trailer i was
like who is this person it took me a
very long time to google but i think i
found him so el aguila which means the
eagle in english his real name is
alejandra montoya and he was born in
spain and then moved to the united
states to become a crime-fighting
superhero that likes to steal money from
criminals to distribute it to the poor
very much like robin hood and um very
cool i wish that he was he actually
existed in real life because i could use
some of that drug money to pay my bills
i will willingly take your drug money
exactly
but he's actually a mutant in the marvel
comics we have another appearance of a
mutant in the mcu which is very cool so
is he
a an actual criminal
i guess you're a criminal because you're
still stealing from the rich
exactly so like he's
because vigilantism is a crime like he
is perceived as a criminal in the eyes
of the american government but he's
actually doing some good and he actually
teams up with man and iron fist at one
point in the comics so like he's just
like a misunderstood hero um but his
mutant power is he has the ability to
generate bio electricity out of his body
much like a miles morales and he shoots
that bioelectricity through the sword
that he has that you can see in the um
in his hilt in the she-hulk trailer so i
really hope that we get to see that in
action
because that's a sweet power like just
shooting lightning bolts out of your
body that through your sword that's
super dope all about it but there's also
a mysterious fourth person in this group
uh who we don't really know and it's
this mysterious man in black um who i
think could actually be wakandan just
judging by the bracelets that he has and
the way that he's dressed because he's a
black man
not every black man's wakandan so i'm
gonna put that out there first like i'm
not just like me
just like me in this wig i am not storm
uh not every black person with a white
hair is stored
i thought i bet you did
yeah wrong franchise
but like i i have this weird feeling
that this dude could be some type of
weird wakandan villain that like no one
has ever
like has appeared once and then never
saw again uh but i don't really know who
this guy could be could he like i think
that he could be maybe a baron blood
potentially or um i don't know who do
you think this guy could oh i don't know
who that is but i really hope they don't
give it to someone that um was like a
villain of black panther that i
genuinely do want to see because i feel
like most of these people are just in
this for this scene i'm more interested
in who put them in there because i don't
think this is like um
this is a support group that she's
joining i think they're still monitoring
abomination and these are one of the
things he does while locked up is talk
to other people so uh i don't
i just i i watch them all have been put
away by like matt murdock but
i don't
i don't i think she's just following
because he's probably like eventually
he's probably gonna be like we're no
we're not different you and me we both
didn't really kind of want this after we
got it and then on top of that like
we're angry all the time for something
we can't control so well they can
control it now but like or she can so
i'm like maybe
maybe she's just following him and maybe
that black man in all black is hopefully
just not
i'm just thinking of characters that
black panther fights and i'm like i hope
it's none of them because i like them
right save all the wakandans for like a
black panther movie not as a joke okay
save all the frog mans exactly
save rock man for civil war ii he will
uh he will stop the fight uh okay
that's ridiculous all right um but those
are just the you know other criminals of
this group but we still have to ask
ourselves the big question here what the
hell is abomination up to you because
whatever the hell emil blonsky is up to
here has got to be some hulk sized
[ __ ] because like i don't think that
this angry man has just suddenly turned
a new leaf like i just think cause like
he was just fighting in shangchi's like
underground street fighting ring so it's
like like i think that was just to get
his energy out if you're locked up what
do we know about like uh confinement
just like solitary confinement it drives
people insane and i wouldn't be
surprised if they were nervous of having
that same situation happen to like
people with superpowers so they're like
they need to get out every once in a
while and let out their anger but also i
feel like wong is just breaking him out
because he's like
we can you're the only sparrow that i
can spar with i don't think he's like no
one's really on our level
i could see him now
not turning a new leaf i feel like me
and abomination are no different where
it's like i didn't turn a new leaf i can
easily change back to being bad but i'm
in this prison
if i try to escape i'm gonna get shot
with like 50 different laser guns
there's no point in that why don't i
just make the best of what i'm doing in
here but i am trying to get out um and i
think he respects jennifer walters for
that in the series i think he's gonna be
like
we're not too far off yeah bruce was an
[ __ ] but you're not bruce clearly
he's like i'm sorry for punching your
cousin but like you know me and you also
he kind of deserved it but you don't
deserve it he deserved it you didn't
right
he deserved it because like he was you
know being a little baby but you you're
[ __ ] totally you're cool you can head
you bring a really good point about like
how he is a prisoner that needs
recess time he needs to be able to go
out
you know outside and like get some his
energy out and so like wong is the
perfect person to sort of like usher
that in for him because like he is the
manager of the monsters in the mcu as
the sorcerer supreme and so and because
just because like this guy is like gamer
or radiated and we know his origin
doesn't make him any less a monster and
like that is like wong's purview really
it's like all right deal with this
you're the source of supreme just he's a
monster um so yeah he's the perfect
person to for him to to take abomination
out to fight i think that's a really
good idea um yeah i think that in terms
of like a motivation i think that
abomination could just be working the
system and just trying to get himself
out or get himself free so he could um
you know
be an abomination like in real life
again
outside of prison
from the trailers
from the trailers he's not making it
easy
you know i don't know he just seems like
that kind of like nonchalant assholey
guy that's like i don't really care and
so i'm like
what are you doing are you negging me
are you nick
is this this is working
am i working
am i being picked up by abomination
wait wait wait emil blonsky that's a
different story abomination
and that dude's still looking good after
like after all these since we last saw
he's still looking good babe
handsome man but up next jess and i are
going to discuss who we think could be
the main villain for the show but first
we also want to thank helix sleep for
sponsoring this video because sleep is
important and here at new rockstars we
trust helix to protect our sleep with
the best mattresses in the world i have
a helix mattress and recently producer
zach and producer john also got helix
mattresses and they love them so much
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you everybody's
unique and helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot and
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains and
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers producer zack took the quiz and
was matched with the midnight luxe
mattress because he's a side sleeper
that needed a softer mattress and now he
doesn't wake up with a sore shoulder or
neckline like he did with other
mattresses which is very important and
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2021 by gq and
wired magazine so just go to
helixsleep.com
insidemarvel take their two-minute sleep
quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that'll give you the
best sleep of your entire existence they
have a 10-year warranty and you get to
try it out for 100 nights risk-free and
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixleap.com inside
marvel and we also want to thank bluechu
for sponsoring this video because the
news from comic-con has confirmed that
the number of mcu phases isn't the only
thing that is growing if you know what i
mean fellas confidence can take you far
in life it could also help you in the
bedroom and that's where blue chew comes
in blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active ingredient
as viagra and cialis but in chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
which is pretty dope you can take them
anytime day or night so you can plan
ahead or be ready whenever an
opportunity arises and the process is
simple sign up at bluetooth.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days and it's all done online so no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacy blue chews tablets are made
in the usa and prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discrete
package so if you can benefit from some
extra confidence when it's time to
perform blue chew can help and we've got
a special deal for our fans try
bluetooth for free when you use our
promo code marvel at checkout just pay
five dollars shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code marvel to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluechu for sponsoring this video
and podcast all right so
our next question big question for
she-hulk here is who is going to be the
main villain of the series because i
don't think the show was really like
fully defined or like shown us who's
going to be the main main villain um
because i mean here's a list of known
villains that we know we know titania is
going to be in the show which you know i
don't think she's the main villain i
think she's gonna become the best friend
right i think they're gonna i i think
only because i and this is genuinely
just from me liking titania from the
comics
they could easily make them still like
uh nemesis or whatever but like right i
like the idea of her becoming the only
person she can spar with that's like
practicing and good for her and i feel
like eventually
because titania is just so wild i think
eventually she's gonna be like
yeah this sounds actually like a good
idea i could we can fight together
right no i really like that idea because
like i i like how like the mcu likes to
like
subvert tropes or like like subvert our
expectations rather because like we know
that like the squirrels in captain
marvel we thought they were going to be
bad guys but they ended up being you
know good guys and friends with carol
danvers so i think that this might be
happening here with titania as well
because it's like yeah i'm really mean
and like i'm supposed to be as this
villain but like i'm just a social media
influencer who
you know just has these weird powers and
like i don't really know what i'm doing
and like we could be friends if i just
stopped doing crime for a second um i
think she's like
i think that'd be a really fun um hero
or anti-hero at the very least to have
yeah
just like hey i'd love her to be the
part of jennifer walters or just a part
to she hulk that's like you don't have
to be so
cautious all the time like you can be
confident with yourself and still do
these things i do it i think that's like
the juxtaposition because we see what
she-hulk looks like from the trailers
and we saw titania's photos and it's
like that woman oozes confidence
oh yeah that woman is straight up her
suit outfit stance compared to like she
hulks that is constantly like trying
really hard i've been like oh yeah she's
gonna teach her to be confident in
herself oh yeah like that's a huge um
like thing that these two have in common
i feel because i feel like before they
turned into um like the super powered
versions of themselves they weren't as
confident as they they were and so um i
feel because with jennifer walters in
the comics like she was very much like
very a lot more meek and a lot like a
lot more um yeah like timid and then
when she becomes she-hulk she's like
yeah like i'm more confident i can be a
lawyer i can i can be more social so
like i think like they were gonna bond
over that it's like hey like these
powers are great because like you know
they help us be more ourselves and to
embrace who we are so like let's be
friends
and uh
fight the real villain whoever that is
um because we have a bunch of villains
in the show like the wrecking crew who
we see in uh in various pieces of pro
material i cannot wait to see how they
are in action because the wrecking crew
is ridiculous in the comics um so i hope
hopefully they're just as really
ridiculous here
um but do you think that the wrecking
crew is going to be the main villain for
this show
no i think they're hired by someone else
okay do you have an idea of like who
potentially could be uh my whole thing
is i don't like the man from the
trailers with the white hair that's like
she's like
me goat me defending him is kind of oh
he is a root of something and i don't
think it's a good something and i think
because in the comics there's a series
where she's like
she works for a really great law firm
but they're straight up just like oh
well we only hired you because you'd
bring us celebrities you'd bring us
superheroes so i think he's one of those
people that's like stirring up stuff
just to bring in more money for himself
so that's why
i don't think a lot of people are
boo
uh and then i get hit by a car and i'm
like please help me
it's my money and i need it now
jg wet world
that's my last words
sorry
okay sorry okay anyways we have to be on
track daschle gave me a look that was
mad
um if you guys if you guys don't know my
best friend daschle he's our cameraman
here at uh rockstars hello daschle he's
my best friend but i think he's i think
they're ran by that guy or someone else
higher i think we're still not seeing it
i think we're still not seeing the big
bad it's kind of like um black panther i
think we're portrayed to see that uh
to not cuerta and think that he's gonna
be neymar is gonna be the bad guy and i
don't think he clearly isn't like he
clearly is not there's someone else
there right here so i think i've seen it
yeah red herring yeah there's a red
herring keep going though no okay now i
like this idea of like she-hulk's boss
being the secret villain because like we
know that some sketchy stuff is
happening in the mcu we know that like
someone or some entities are
trying to start a new world order as we
can see from captain america new world
order announcement so like maybe um the
actual law firm is being controlled by
somebody evil and is making the wrecking
crew for evil purposes i can see that i
can see that
um but we also have obviously the
abomination emil blonsky who is uh you
know trying to turn a new leaf with this
abomaste namaste
thing but like he could potentially be
the big villain what do you think i
think he's gonna be as bad as baron zemo
um that makes sense like not as bad as
in like kill a lot of innocent people
the frame [ __ ] escape i mean like
yeah yeah yeah i meant more so the baron
that we see in uh falcon in the winter
soldier
where it's like once he gets what he
wants he's gonna get he's gonna run away
which will be bad ultimately but i don't
think he's going to be our big bad okay
like you could see like a team up
between uh abomination shield briefly
until like he's like all right peace out
i think he'll also like uh baron zemo
and falcon and bucky he'll be like
working with them he's like yeah i'm
working for you guys i'm helping you but
also ultimately i'm helping myself
and i'm going to get out of here
all right i can see that i can see that
a lot and like i could see him
like maybe escaping and then like
getting caught again by like the
thunderbolts people it's like all right
you're not going to escape us
oh derek he's like oh another
okay i'd be so mad
yeah if i just got out of prison and
then they put me on a government team
like suicide squad i'd be so mad about
that it's like i was chilling in prison
i was doing less work take me back yeah
put me back in prison put me back in
prison i'm not staying here um but we
also have like in our promo material
these freaky mutant dogs that she hulk
fights i don't know where these guys
come from but since we know that wong is
gonna be a big presence in the show
could these freaky mutant dogs be wong
related in some like capacity do you not
think i keep just thinking uh when she
has to get statements from people she
gets statements from wong for
abomination because he's been the only
one clearly hanging out with him and
he's probably like abomination's a good
guy and he she's like well
just because you fight with him doesn't
make him doesn't make him a good guy
just because you spar with him does not
make him a good person right uh because
that's how i was taking it uh as wong's
role would it be like
yeah i'm just here to give a statement
right and then i'm gonna go
zhu zhu i mean like
i can see him having like a really quick
cameo um just be like all right
he's a great guy
bye
um but so
no i don't think the mutant dogs are
from him but they again a higher person
it's a higher person and they are coming
i mean like we do know from like uh i
believe it was the the eric banner hulk
films like there was these weird mutant
dogs in that movie um and i'm wondering
if someone in the mcu is like sort of
replicating that through gamma
radiations be like all right let's make
let's put some gamma radiation on dogs
or maybe some of um hulk's blood that
was uh in uh the hulk
like there's literally a whole lab of
hulk blood that um the leader made um
against bruce banner's will and he
didn't know and so like that has still
not been addressed in the mcu so maybe
these dogs are made out of this blood or
maybe a titania was made out of his
blood who knows but that's just me
saying weird [ __ ] um but there's also
another possibility here consider like
speaking of the 2008 hulk film the
leader um samuel stearns who we have not
seen
since the very beginning or since the
2008 hulk film he uh he hit his head and
he got some of bruce's blood on his oh
yes yeah and now and it got all really
weird and big um so we haven't seen him
since that moment in on the incredible
hulk so do you think that she-hulk could
have the leader as its villain that i
could see
if that was a rogue theory i'd give it a
rogue
because they do it's not like they're
not pulling they
have they like officially said that the
2008 hulks are canon well in the the
what if episode there was a what-if
episode with mark ruffalo basically
taking the place of edward norton so i'm
thinking that the mcu is just saying
that yeah this is like
the same thing we bring in
it makes me mad because it's like we
bring in emil blonsky so i'm like yes
but not everything is a yes uh it's just
they also brought in uh ross of course
before the actors passed yeah yeah
yeah exactly so that's why i'm like the
maybe they do bring in the leader maybe
the leader is the big bad i would see
that more so i just i think it'd be
really fun i would love to see that
actor again because like he's just she's
really good really he's really great as
like a nerd type character who uh just
gets too like too out of control with
his curiosity um so i would love to see
the leader factor it again because like
i just feel like that's a thread that
needs to be pulled because like if they
left it open-ended and like you have to
answer that because like it's been yeah
since the beginning of the mcu like
literally they'll say
it would be fun if her and obama
abomination and uh she-hulk took him
down
and then abomination runs away
and then after the fight's done
abominations big ass just
running through them
you know i would love if they both work
together to take him down and then
abominations like well i'm gonna fight
you now she'll now that we won and then
like she-hulk takes him down and then
they both go to thunderbolt prison
where they have to be thunderbolts
i think we're getting a small team up of
like super friends and normal human
friends in she-hulk because i think
there's potential for abomination her to
fight alongside each other for at least
a bit but i know her and titania will
like i know her and titania will fight
together and honestly what i'm pitching
about abomination could happen with
titania they could be fake friends and
the titania is like [ __ ] slap bye
and then dips into the woods like it
could easily happen i would love that
[ __ ]
just when she's oh what's that and then
i hope she said the words [ __ ] slap
while she's [ __ ]
hopefully hey it's a titanium move let
me tell you a sucker punch to the back
of the head i got you
um but out of that entire list the
leader is the one that i would lean more
of the lean okay
me too actually because i just feel like
the rest of those guys are just like
supporting characters or like really fun
people to have in the show alright so
for our final question of today
jess what do you think wong's role is
going to be in this show i think
it's the yeah we're in the long
cinematic universe but i do think that
like the cameos the cameos will get
smaller and the cameos will be just as
fun just as fun when i say smaller
doesn't mean hey fun things come in
small packages so right that's what i'm
saying it's what i've said every day
he's like i say this every night and
they still don't believe me
um
but i think i i think he is just there
for a statement because he also like if
they're persecuting prosecuting
abomination we're definitely going to
look back at who abomination has like
already aligned himself with and i think
she's going to be like you've been
either sneaking him out or knowingly
taking him out to fight him and then
bringing him back to his little hole
his little glass room so it's like what
what about him seems like it's changed
does he deserve a shorter sentence or a
longer sentence and he's going to be
like why are you sensing people i feel
like wong's going to come with the
mindset of like prisons aren't good
and
she's going to be like well i follow the
justice system and he's like the book of
a shot
and that's where we get there
yeah she was like oh you guys would do
less spending on money if you follow my
book right but no um i i do like this
idea of wong just coming in as like a
support and like being sort of like the
like since the united states government
knows more about the the knights of
commerce and all the warriors of
commerce i think it'd be great for like
the i think it makes sense for the
united states to have an agreement with
them just being like all right if
there's a weird mystical thing you can
come in and like do a thing it can like
help us manage it because we can't do it
on our own police can't freaking stop
abomination let's be real um but yeah i
think it makes a lot of sense for for
him to be that way but he also says in
the trailer that the universe is at a
precipice and that's really interesting
to me because i don't really know what
he could mean by that because it sounds
really like like something big is coming
and that potentially could be introduced
in the she-hulk show so and we know that
from the trailers that there's this
ridiculous character uh marvel villain
called the magician um who
appears very briefly and i'm wondering
if the magician and wong could have like
uh like some type of history together
like the or
he could potentially be um i don't know
using black magic i would see that more
with we and we talked about this on the
break room with the hood
more so because that's person already
being set up now for iron heart so why
not start them with this um
not that saying that his mystical arts i
guess would align with wong's but both
mystical
it's all mystical it's all magic
i just can't wait to see wong in a
courtroom
just just because it's like literally so
minuscule to them like
but
like a superhero that literally has to
save the world from monsters and goes
through dimensions literally has to sit
in a courtroom for four hours yeah and
listen to people recant their
stories freaking abomination that's
that's why i use the the runes of cough
call and have everyone forget about the
whole situation like all right i'm done
yeah i'm like
i'm done with this and then and then
your friend abomination kills a bunch of
innocent people and you're like oh damn
it right and then you just have them
forget i made a mistake have all their
friends and family and the victims
forget who they were you keep being like
jesus christ you're an only child your
entire life
please
you didn't have a family god get over
but no like you know what i can't
potentially see happening in the show is
uh wong
um coming into like with help the
prosecution of agatha harkness because
agatha yeah oh 100
in new jersey 100 100 and they're
definitely like she must be working with
that doctor strange fellow and he's like
absolutely not
we've got two different magics
not affiliated with us let us keep our
school and keep doing ourselves i don't
know what that woman
you don't know
you guys remember the salem witch trials
that's her
she was everywhere
nope
nope
you better leave me out of it and that
would be so hard for people like me to
understand that world i'd be like but
you both do magic and it'd be like two
different magic there's two different
types
it's like pepsi and cola
yeah and i'm like it's the same thing
you could have stopped her
right
and i honestly feel like catherine hahn
is perfect for this type of show it's
like really goofy and it's really fun
and catherine is like really good at
oh my god so like it would be perfect if
that's
if that's just the case we haven't seen
yet but we'll see is the
like the court of catherine of agatha
harkness and she's still like do you
want tea and cookies because she's
living in the 50s
well that would be so insane i would
love that and i hope she-hulk gives me
that yeah cause like i feel like that
raises a really interesting legal like
conundrum it's like do we prosecute a
person that is no longer themselves like
can we do that
honestly if she-hulk wants more seasons
that's what it should do is like there's
so many times we watch these things and
we're like like even all of civil war
was your choosing a side right and if we
had a legal battle to figure out who was
literally her fault might be nice coming
from a superhero like jennifer walters
because she's like well i'm on both
sides now um that is what i also need i
just need jennifer walters doing it i
don't want two people that aren't
superheroes doing it because they'll be
like they killed a bunch of people right
i don't think the person the perfect
like middle ground it's like i'm a
superhero but also
normal
no not at all uh
she does what she wants this is her
world we're just living in it
but that is it for this episode of
inside marvel i want to thank jessica
for joining me on this episode she is
amazing please follow her at luluclemons
on twitter and support whatever she does
she's amazing but also do not forget to
check out our many merch options over at
new rockstarsmerch.com and if you're
over 18 click the link in the
description box below to join our new
rockstars discord server it's amazing
and uh it's really fun so if you're
searching rockstars or click the link
below you can join that conversation
today you can follow me at master
chamber if you want to see me sweet some
weird [ __ ] and really fun theories but
most importantly you subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcast
thank you guys so much for watching we
love you guys so much and we'll see you
guys later goodbye
[Music]
foreign